in the middle east where a u.s military
attack sends an unmistakable message to
iran
the overnight airstrikes targeted
iranian-backed militia members in
eastern syria
near the iraq border the pentagon says
this was a response to recent attacks on
u.s targets in iraq
one of them killed a civilian contractor
and wounded several other people
including
a u.s service member defense secretary
lloyd austin told reporters he's
confident u.s
forces had struck the same militias that
carried out that attack
senior foreign affairs correspondent and
face the nation moderator margaret
brennan joins us
margaret good morning what's behind the
decision to carry out this attack
well this is the first military strike
of the biden presidency and as
commander-in-chief the president chose a
target
along the syria-iraq border he chose it
carefully
so that it would count as payback for
iran having put u.s personnel in harm's
way
last week in a rocket attack but
stopping
short of further escalating tension an
administration official
told me that the biden team selected the
location to achieve those two things
and avoid ticking off our partners on
the ground in baghdad who are stuck
between keeping good relations with both
iran
and washington uh as our david martin
reported previously this was considered
iranian-enabled these were iranian-made
weapons
given to a shiite militia but not
iranian directed so by striking along
the border they can
send a message but not have to take
tehran on
head on so margaret what do you think
this says about the new president's
approach to foreign policy
well it shows how important keeping his
options open with iran
are to him he is trying to avoid
escalating tension
but also felt he couldn't let this go he
had to send a signal remember just last
week
the biden administration put out two
diplomatic fishing lines one to reopen
nuclear talks with iran
and also to start talks about releasing
american hostages there
so by picking this target carefully
they can say knock it off without saying
all
other options to begin talks are closed
margaret the biden administration
is set to release a report that ties the
saudi crown prince to the murder
of journalist jamal khashoggi president
biden spoke with the saudi king
yesterday what do we know about that
conversation
this is an important relationship for
the united states the 85 year old king
salman and biden had to have this
conversation about the broader
relationship
and then this very problematic issue of
the sun the 30-something-year-old crown
prince and his
direct role in approving the murder of
the journalist is something that they
would really like to be
able to uh handle without disrupting the
broader
alliance between the two countries but
the binding administration is kind of in
a box here they have to look responsive
the president talked about this on the
campaign trail
so what you can expect is for them to
try to send a message
i would expect in the coming days to
hear from the administration that
they're going to adopt a new policy
directive
that sends a signal do not attack u.s
journalists but that it won't just apply
to saudi
that way they can look responsive
without being
really sort of provocative between the
two countries
margaret brennan thank you margaret